un français sur deux possède un jardin
en tout cas un coin de balcon où il
cultive quelques fleurs et quelques
plantes tous ces jardiniers à mites
amateurs pour en cette fin de semaine
d'échangés les secrets des mains vertes
avec des professionnels
oui comme chaque année la commune de
courson dans l'essonne organise deux
week-ends de rencontre l'un au printemps
l'autre à l'automne actuellement si vous
vous y rendez donc ce week-end vous
rencontrerez peut-être had marie et yvon
ce couple de retraités de la région
parisienne a fait naître autour de sa
maison un jardin vraiment extraordinaire
regard des reportages claude crespo
frédéric de la rue
je leur dit qu'elles sont belles je
redis qu'il me donne du bonheur est fier
en passage les bouscule je suis désolé
plus je retiens excusez moi j'ai du
plaisir à être dans mon jardin en est
qu'il est très beau je suis ravi mais je
pense pas qu'il y ait de main verte
il faut s'occuper beaucoup des plantes
les aimez mais s'en occuper beaucoup
être là à leur semaine tous les instants
et anne-marie sait de quoi il parle il
ya 20 ans ici une friche de 1000 mètres
carrés
aujourd'hui son jardin une oasis où
cohabitent 190 espèces de roses 55 de
clématites et plus de 300 de plantes
vivaces
je voulais que ce soit quelque chose qui
soit qui sortent de moi qui soit le
reflet de ma personnalité donc bombay et
vous avez l'impression d'avoir réussi
est-ce que ce jardin c'est vraiment le
jardin d'anne marie metz et le jardin
que j'aime
ils vont le mari le reconnaît lui-même
au départ ils étaient moins fanas de
rose surtout quand il a dû s'atteler aux
gros travaux
mais il n'a pas longtemps résisté à la
passion de son épouse une passion qui a
un prix - de coiffure pour elle - de
voyage pour deux en échange des fleurs
tout le temps et partout
elles ont même envahi le jardin d'hiver
une hypocrisie dans un jardin ça aussi
c'est une chose
tranquille ça va portes du calme les
fleurs vous rendrez exactement ce que
vous leur donnez quelques fois même plus
un plus que 300 visiteurs ont pu à la
bonne saison
admirez pour 30 francs anne-marie joue
les guides conseils partage ses secrets
et reçoit les compliments mérités pour
ce qu'elle appelle son quatrième bébé
un enfant qui lui réclame tout de même
huit heures de tension par jour